une information effectivement très
importante même si évidemment l'élection
Nouvelle-Calédonie
va pas être dupliqué au niveau France
entière et en tout cas dans les
départements où il y a un renouvellement
oui alors c'est la première fois qu'un
dentiste arrive au Sénat bon évidemment
s'il faut le saluer il y a quelque chose
bon et puis il y a aussi je dirais c'est
presque l'information qui va peut-être
l'emporter immédiatement dans la dans le
commentaire politique il y a une
ministre du gouvernement qui est battu
qui est battu extrêmement sèchement
ce qui alors
c'est toujours assez compliqué à
interpréter mais on peut penser que
c'est pas son rapport avec le processus
actuel de de discussion sur l'avenir
institutionnel de la Calédonie etc en
tout cas là on a une défaite très nette
du camp gouvernemental qui va avoir
peut-être des conséquences dans les
semaines ou les mois à venir sur la
façon dont
le gouvernement français va poursuivre
ou construire sa négociation sur
l'avenir institutionnel de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie
[Musique]